Memorize the alpha and beta receptors
in under 60 seconds.
Guys, I've made this so easy.
So recall, there's 4 receptors.
Alpha one, alpha 2,
beta one, beta 2.
And there's 4 simple rules.
Now, the first rule is that one.
So whether it's alpha one or beta one,
it's always gonna affect the heart,
because we have one heart.
If it's 2, alpha 2 or 2,
it affects the lungs because we have 2 lungs.
Now, we're gonna use this really simple pneumonic
A, B, C, D. Now, A always goes with C
because we want a C or we're gonna have a bad day.
So B and D go together.
C stands for constrict,
D stands for dilate.
So alpha always constricts,
beta always dilates.
So if we put this all together,
let's say we have alpha 2.
Well, alpha always constricts.
2 always affects the lungs,
so it constricts the lungs.
There you have it.